a igualdade é que vocês querem ocupar
mundo já se perguntaram isso
em dado momento do ensino médio a minha
professora de história também dá aula de
projetos de vida me fez o seguinte
questionamento qual é o lugar que você
quer para o mundo
eu não sabia a resposta mas também
imaginava que pensar sobre isso me
fizessem chegar tantas possibilidades de
crescimento e de futuro
eu venho de uma família muito humilde
a maioria veio de rondônia onde eles
trabalhavam na roça e quando eu tinha um
ano mais ou menos eles vieram para são
paulo
apesar de todas as dificuldades que a
família enfrentou
eles sempre fizeram questão de me
garantiu melhor e sempre me deram todo
apoio que eu precisava e a eles devo
todo o agradecimento perto da minha casa
havia uma escola na qual foi matriculada
no ensino fundamental
e essa escola era considerada pior
escola da região
a maioria dos professores não mostrava
compromisso as aulas eram canceladas eo
desinteresse era geral
obviamente eu não me sentia um pouco
motivada quando chegou a hora de ir para
o ensino médio
surgiu uma nova escola ao lado dessa
outra uma escola em tempo integral
chamada jardim riviera
eu sempre gostei de estudar mas a
maioria dos meus amigos tinha ficado na
escola antiga então fiquei em dúvida
será que eu vou não
então que surgiu a minha mãe me
incentivando pra caramba e falando que
deveria mudar eu mudei de escola e
conseqüentemente a minha vida mudou
essa escola também é pública mas ela era
muito melhor e logo de cara tinha a
sensação de acolhimento enorme
lá eu tive contato com um projeto
chamado protagonismo juvenil que é um
projeto onde jovens que têm destaque
acadêmico tem a oportunidade de
influenciar outros jovens e estes jovens
disseminam essas lições nas suas escolas
e durante todo o ensino médio eu fui me
tornando uma das principais
representantes do estado de são paulo em
termos de protagonismo juvenil
bom esse projeto
toinho lado pró ativo e como a escola
também havia disciplinas eletivas a
chance de escolher aquilo que eu queria
me levou a cursar uma disciplina chamada
pré iniciação científica dentre os
projetos possíveis trabalhar com plantas
é algo muito acessível então eu fui até
um parque perto da minha casa e laudo
indicará com uma árvore enorme chamado
embaúba que segundo a sabedoria popular
tinha propriedades cicatrizantes e na
uva é uma árvore endémica do brasil todo
mundo conhece é uma planta tem muitas
propriedades inclusive pessoas da minha
família conheceu pesquisando na internet
eu vi que a hipótese da propriedade
cicatrizantes se confirmava mas não
tinha nada científico a respeito
como assim mas foi tão importante e nada
sobre era o que eu precisava para
iniciar o projeto
depois da inicial eu pensei na melhor
maneira de usar a planta então 'ficha
suco pomada e sabonete eu cheguei a
fazer papel reciclado com a planta as
idéias estavam acabando
é o chá eles tinham gosto até aceitável
mas em grandes quantidades e ele tem
potencial alucinógeno não experimenta um
suco
ele tinha um gosto horrível então
ninguém queria experimentar as mulheres
dizem que emagrece
a pomada eu testei deu super certo e eu
vi que ali poderia existir a chance de
desenvolver um projeto bem legal
o último laboratório que me permitisse
avançar a pesquisa eu tive que buscar
parcerias
eu conseguia parceria de algumas
universidades dentre elas a unifesp e
essas universidades me ajudaram a
desenvolver melhor o projeto filho
identificação da espécie
o mapeamento das propriedades
farmacológicas fiz uma bateria de testes
e no final das contas eu aproveitei a
bobeira cicatrizante e essa lei vários
prêmios cheguei a publicar um artigo
científico e hoje vários alunos daquela
escola fazem pesquisa eo meu projeto é
um exemplo para muitos deles são grande
orgulho
com todo esse incentivo conta com toda
a esse entusiasmo né de fazer pesquisa
eu posso ensino médio querendo cursar
farmácia e eu saí da pior escola da
minha região conseguir a aprovação em
todos os vestibulares que eu prestei eu
fui
não parei refletir e decidir que
engenharia era algo muito mais próximo
do que eu queria para o meu futuro
hoje eu tenho 18 anos está no segundo
ano de curso pretendo me formar em
engenharia de energia porque não me
agrada nem um pouco saber que um país
com a extensão territorial tão grande e
com tanta diversidade de climas ainda
recorre a termelétricas em tempos de
estiagem e ao mesmo tempo tem tão pouca
diversificação da matriz energética
eu ainda não tenho resposta para a
questão inicial mas através da educação
eu descobri que a menor vontade de
crescer e mudar a vida das pessoas ao
meu redor
na minha vida existirão dois tipos de
escola mas nunca me desmotivou e nunca
me fez parar então hoje eu quero servir
de inspiração para muitos jovens assim
como eu tive várias fontes de inspiração
ao longo da minha vida eu quero fazer
com que esses jovens acredita no seu
talento e não seu esforço pessoal e
possam buscar os seus sonhos e mudar
suas vidas e o mundo
a gente nunca pode dizer que sonho de
uma pessoa são bobagens
seriam apenas e todas as pessoas
acreditassem isso você é do tamanho do
seu sonho não importa o lugar onde você
veio onde você nasceu
se você tem um sonho e se dedica para
que as coisas dêem certo acredita em mim
as coisas acontecem já assistiram alice
no país das maravilhas
lembram do gato pra quem não sabe onde
vai qualquer caminho serve então a
questão que fica é qual o tamanho do
sonho de vocês
e qual é o lugar que vocês querem ocupar
mundo muito obrigada
[Aplausos]